hello everyone everyone can hear me okay
today basically I'm going to talk about
a problem that we've all faced as data
scientists we're always trying to decide
actually in general
well what's better when we're designing
a model or we're choosing a pre-trained
network or whatever we happen to be
doing and the reason I'm talking about
this I should give you a little
background I'm actually not a
statistician even though that's my title
I studied computational neuroscience and
I'm only in the industry for a couple
years now and so I just happened to
notice there's this pattern that keeps
repeating everywhere I go and it led me
to a little confusion so first my name
is Noah but I don't have animals or arcs
or anything like it so we can skip the
jokes we have two main data science
offices a Twix were pretty big division
but we're relatively new and always
growing so basically this is what I saw
I started to look at papers and I
noticed they tend to end in a very
similar way right they did the end with
our network is better than the other
guys right like we we compared it on
some enormous test set some industry
standard which were all together
overfitting - and as a giant
organization yeah so we're all comparing
these test sets right and we built these
neural networks
I don't like let's just call them bags
of linear algebra as a computational
neuroscientists call neural networks is
just offensive but okay so these bags of
linear algebra and that whose entire
concept entire philosophy is statistical
inference right we're trying to guess
something based on historical knowledge
about something that we don't it know
and we made it all the way to the end we
trained on this huge data set and we
thought about data augmentation we
thought about all sorts of network
architectures and we came up with all
these really cool concepts and get us to
some results and then we decide which
one is better based on a point estimate
a number right like we get some tests we
compare on some test set and we said oh
look at this one here this is actually
no algorithm right and we look at the
precision and we say okay not at all got
0.83 for as its you know it's this if
you happy with this loss function fine
we've got point eight three four and if
you don't do anything really you get
point eight two one I don't know is
point eight three for higher than twenty
to one I mean it's just it's a single
number it's very hard to make any more
statistical inferences from a single
number but we just built this entire
neural network an entire bag of the
nodes we trained for four days and we
collected all this data and we had
labels and we had all this stuff and in
the end we're happy with saying yeah
point a three four that's the highest
it's fine so we did the same thing here
look oh this guy's algorithm is the
recall is the best a point seven forty
two and overall the f1 score is
definitely the best when considering its
dependent on the precision recall that's
not very surprising so yeah definitely
point 704 is definitely better than
point six nine one we're happy we can
now choose which network we're going to
start with so we end up sometimes when
we're just trying to choose on this
thing is very directional so um so we're
trying to choose now which one is better
so if you would if you were the paper's
authors you'd obviously select your
favorite one time on which one is better
so the authors would like you to believe
that there one is better cuz that's the
highest number came out they have some
good excuses though look training takes
a long time it's a big neural network
it's got a lot of hidden layers and what
are we gonna do our data set is huge we
got tons of images in our data set yeah
so I mean nothing we could do we can't
like bootstrap it or run some
cross-validation it would take us a year
to get the end of our results so what
can you do let's take the point estimate
that's fine so this is my has been my
experience in the last two years I don't
know have you guys kind of felt the same
way that you did all this work and you
got to this point then you ended up with
a single number you're like okay and you
went to your boss you're like yeah my
precision is better than the other guys
precision I'm not really sure if always
but at least you know on the test set
that I tried it looks the best so yeah
that's a problem that we've had so is
choosing the top score better per se
that's one and there's another issue
that we have even if we
a new kind of nice fancy stuff for a
general classification problem well we
chose a couple of four architectures or
we chose a couple different approaches I
used xgb and this one used SVM and I use
this neural network architecture and the
other guy used another or whatever or
even just me and in the end I want to
know which one is best and generally
what we all do right we we chose three
different algorithms and we choose the
one that came up with the highest number
on the test set that we randomly
selected right so we did all this work
in statistical inference and then the
last final tiny step at the very end of
all the work we just chose the highest
one so let's just do I call that first
chapter forgetting statistics right
because we worked all that way and then
we forgot statistics so I just wanted to
do a little thought experiment with you
all just to kind of show you why it's
actually not always a good idea to
choose just the top one so here's my
thought experiment
that's my four month old this was when
he was younger but my four month old
baby who by the way decided to wake up
every single hour last night so I'm
sorry in advance from like rambling or
saying nonsense fortunately it's not
very hard to tell when he's happy or sad
because he makes very expressive faces
like the one he made at me at 3:00 a.m.
he's extremely happy to be awake you
didn't need a very strong classifier to
figure out my expression on but he was
very happy so we're gonna just classify
my my son's emotions okay but we're not
gonna use your fancy neural network no
we're just gonna use two coins so I have
a bronze coin and I have a silver cord
and I have a hundred pictures sometimes
when he's happy sometimes when he's sad
right and we're gonna use the coins to
classify my son's emotions okay so let's
look at our first model model number one
the bronze coin so like I showed you
here right and this particular 100th
Rose you've got 53 heads in 47 tails and
as you can see this is the reality I got
27 heads let's assign heads to be sad
right so I got 27 true SADS and well 26
times let's not talk about those and
four tails say these are happy so I got
you know 24 true Happy's and the other
ones let's talk about
so I have a second model though I have a
gold coin and oh I want to tell you in
advance these are these are fair coins
but in this case yeah I threw it a
hundred times
and I got 24 and 25 and 26 25 let's just
do a quick little calculation here let's
think about the precision in the recall
for motor 1 our precision was 51 wow
it's like 5% better than model 2 and I
recall I sorry our precision was
dependent our recall was 54 versus 48
like a huge improvement much bigger than
point 8 2 1 versus point 8 34 right
and by the way of nicely showing you
here the f1 is 53 which if anyone hasn't
been thinking too long about F scores
right so which quanti makes the better
classifier easy choice let's choose the
highest right definitely the bronze coin
let's go with the bronze coin right
everyone satisfied it's a great model
the bronze coin is definitely better
than the silver one so a bad method
clearly the current method of selecting
the top score leads us to absurd results
right that's my basic point and a better
method would tell you what is
particularly obvious in this case that
with a hundred pictures of my son happy
and sad the coins are indistinguishable
right and that would then we would go
and make a logical choice but a good
excuse though right like I mentioned we
can't bootstrap we can't cross validate
we can't do any of those tricks on our
training set our training set is huge
and our training takes a long time so
let me give you a proposed solution
what's a proposed solution what should
it do what would you want in a good
solution a good solution first well it
should give you some kind of hints about
how the model is gonna be performing
right now a test set what you hope when
you take a test set is it exactly
represents the kind of classes that
you're going to see in real life right
but you took one sub sample right okay
so good a good some good solution should
be able to give you some indication how
well your models going to perform what
else well it should help you to tell
models apart right if one is actually
different than the other and if it is
which one's the best one right one -
which is the worst one and then even
better well your test set was just a sub
sample so what I'd really like to know
is well how likely are my
class is going to my class balance is
going to change yeah so if I'm very
confident I know there's actually 10
times as many dogs as there are cats and
I have a dog and clack classifier fine I
could be happy with that but you might
also have a situation where you know I'm
not sure whether it's always exactly
10:00 to 1:00 and so I don't want to
know what my model is going to do if the
test set exactly replicates the reality
I also want to know what happens if the
test set is not a perfect representation
of exactly what I'm going to see in real
life right basically the probability of
a class appearing in your test set is
also a random variable okay so I'm gonna
give you a quick overview of the
solution it doesn't solve every single
problem because it's a 25-minute talk
plus I didn't think about it all the way
to the end but but it's going to give us
at least a start to show that the excuse
of we can't cross validate because our
training set is too big is is a lousy
excuse we can still do some stuff okay
so first we have this nice large
training set so if we're in a classical
classification or regression problem
right what we can simply do is we take
our different features for example this
one and we discover that for each class
it has a certain variance right and this
variance has a certain you know we can
select this we know from this variance
we can construct basically a
distribution with a zero mean that has
the variance that we found in our in our
in our training set right and we can do
this for all of our classes and then
let's say you take the yeah just let's
say for a simple solution take the
average variance between the classes but
if we're on a neural network problem we
have to do a little bit more work why
because we can't just for example take
the random distribution of let's say the
input weights or something like that
because then you're starting to go back
and you know mess around with the
algorithm in its first place and we
don't want to do that by the way
everything I'm about to tell you is what
happens when we have already a train
system I'm not talking here about data
augmentation or any of these other
things okay so anyway we have this thing
Sophie let's say we were in the case of
my of what we're trying to decide
whether my son is happy or sad in this
case we have phases right so we might
have phases that come in with different
angles right so instead of looking at
the variance of let's say I don't know
single pixel values or things that are
kind of very low-level we might want to
look at variances
more high order things that actually
would impact the results of our model so
in this case for example if his head is
tilted this way or that way maybe we can
there's some impact on the success of
detecting whether he's happy or sad
because you know a frown is pointing
down and this is pointing that unless
his head is upside down right so then
what we might do is say okay well what
are the what is the distribution of
angles that we actually have in our face
angles that we actually have in our
training set we can say okay well if our
training set is representative of the
world of course if our training set
isn't representative the world our model
is going to suck anyway so there's no
point worried about it so if our
training set is representative of what
we're going to see in the world so we
can take now this distribution of angles
this variance and the angles and create
again a distribution that has zero mean
and a variance that is equal to that of
my mom so and we would do that then for
a lot of different higher order
parameters right so it takes a little
extra work for a neural network but it
takes and it takes a lot less work for a
first and I should also mention if you
have if you have categorical variables
there's also ways to do it what you
could do is one one simple solution is
you one autumn code and then you look at
the binomial variance right P times one
minus P okay so the next thing I'm
offering I'm telling I'm suggesting is
that we sub sample or test it now why do
we sub sample our test set we sub simple
our test set because our test set it's
essentially a simulation of what our
test that is done to the world right
we've subsampled the world with our test
set so let's subsample our test that
like we're substituting the world okay
now on this sub sample let's just add
noise again we add we created a
distribution with zero mean and the
variance that arised from our from our
variables we're gonna add noise now why
do we bother to add noise we bothered
add noise because in that particular
case where we select randomly write a
value for the noise that we're going to
add from the distribution that we
generated so here again is the
distribution we have a zero we add at
zero and it has a variance that we found
from our training set and now we add
noise by plucking randomly from this
distribution and adding it to to one of
our test samples now why is that because
what are the odds of finding the exact
sample that we have in our tested in the
real world right what is the what is the
probability of a single point on a PDF
zero
right and so obviously we're not going
to find that so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take and we're gonna add
variants that we've come to expect from
our training set okay
what's the next step well we classify
our noised subsample okay and at that
point we can just calculate the average
loss right and basically now what am I
suggesting the obvious my bootstrap so
in every iteration what do we do we
subsampled our test set we add a noise
whose corresponding corresponds to the
noise of our training set right and we
estimate our bootstrap loss now as soon
as we do that well first I want to make
a quick word this is PI data so I should
mention a little python this is a very
simple function right all you got to do
is add noise and calculate the loss so
what goes in a trained model a subsample
the test features a subsample of let's
say the test ground truth right and the
future variance which we calculated in
the way that i described and what comes
out the mean lost per iteration and I
don't care what loss function you decide
on yeah so just you take that function
you iterate it and you're done yeah so
this is literally a few lines of code
thanks to them and we take our train
model our sub sample of our test set the
sub sample of our ground truth and this
matrix the future variance matrix that
we found in this case it's very simple
we just add some noise that's based on
that variance right this is a random
distribution and now we calculate what
our log loss is on the noise alright and
we returned that as a
nothing their holy power their holy
independent each iteration or
subsampling we're bootstrapping
yeah we're just bootstrapping but we're
adding a little extra and we're enough
bootstrapping with replacement we're
bootstrapping subset yeah well alright
I'm not talking about Trane we can't
retrain so there's no overfitting
because the the models already trained
now what I'm doing is creating basically
essentially a histogram of what my
errors are so I we did this as a simple
example I just compared random for us to
add a boost in logistic regression I
think it was in the ires ires set and
found something interesting right well
first of all if you were looking at a
point that estimate this overlap between
logistic regression adaboost
essentially tells you what are the odds
you would have chose logistic regression
over adaboost yeah you could see all
this overlapping section well that's the
odds yeah if you take this this integral
right that's the chance that even though
you know by now looking at this nice
beautiful Instagram that you should
definitely choose adaboost because the
error is the lowest sorry I should
really describe this is log loss and
these are simply counts so adaboost has
the lowest log loss but a lot of the
time you would have chose Alyssa
progression also you discovered another
little side benefit here notice what
happens on the data boost right you have
some cases right where the log loss is
suddenly much higher it's a binomial
distribution okay that to me what that
indicates is because we've added noise
some of our our features seem to be very
sensitive to to this jitter which means
we probably need to regularize some of
them right and we did improve a results
so even but even choosing we learned
something extra about our model why
should i why should we have a binomial
bimodal distribution of our error right
it tells us something as weird going on
there without abuse so we got some
insight without even the whole question
of deciding between so one it gives you
a hint how your model is actually gonna
perform right cuz now it's not just you
don't just come to your boss and say
well look I got a I got a log loss of
point zero one three four no you say
well I can tell you that
90% of the time the model is going to
perform between 0.1 and 0.2 log loss
right accuracy or precision or recoil
area under the curve whatever you want
okay what's the other thing it allows
you to tell models apart right so now
you have two histograms you can do any
hypothesis test that you like all right
you want to see if the medians are
different the means are different
anything you want you wanna know if the
shapes are different you can do all the
hypothesis tests that you might think
you might dream up okay so we solved the
first two what I didn't tell you yet is
how reliable your model is given a
different distribution of classes right
so I told you a good solution would
solve all those three don't worry I'm
gonna keep my promises so here what we
did is we subsampled randomly from our
test set you don't actually have to sub
sample randomly for example if I sampled
with an inverse probability I'm gonna
get a uniform distribution of classes
right
in which case basically what I'm saying
is in my error estimate I'm it's equally
important to me whatever class happens
to be yeah now that's clearly not what's
gonna be like in the real world
right I mean we're not gonna have
necessarily equal distribution of
classes but for me I don't care if a cat
only appears one out of ten times I want
to be as wrong with cats as I am with
dogs but we could have because we don't
know this is also in the real world we
can also treat the probability of a
class appearing as a random variable
right as I said before so what does it
mean we can sample with a random
probability and how would we do that
well just an off-the-cuff suggestion
look at your classes right say which one
is the rarest okay calculate what the
binomial variances of that appearing so
if you have a probability of appearing
of let's say 0.1% or whatever 1% of 1%
so then the variance is 10% and now you
can jitter your probabilities when you
select for each sub sample by that 10%
because you can expect that that's gonna
be more or less how your classes are
going to vary see and now it's gonna
give you a much better estimate of what
you'd expect it because the test sample
is only one sample but you know the
lowest the lowest likely has the highest
binomial probability and so what you can
do is you can take basically what you're
doing is you say
well the solids of selecting a
particular class also varies and how
does it vary well it varies with the
most variant of my classes yeah so
that's another little like a trick where
you can add it so if you're really not
sure that my test set is representative
of the class balance I'm gonna say in
reality for the very large industrial
test sets you might not necessarily need
that or for a model where you don't care
you know you want your most frequent
class to be the best then maybe you
don't really care that you're more wrong
on the 10% right so that's basically it
that's the whole that's the whole
algorithm and in that case we really
solved all three of these issues so
quickly what do we do well even though
you can't bootstrap and cross validate
you could still has to make the errors
yeah by adding the noise from the
drivetrain it's up sampling and then
doing these these subsample bootstraps
rather than the bootstrap with
replacement and this way you can get a
kind of judgment on your models which
one you should choose okay so that's
what we succeeded in doing well I
mentioned there's even a better solution
as a bonus but it's a 25-minute talk
it's the last one and I know doing math
as your last few slides is not a good
idea so I'm just going to simply point
out some problems with my solution so
you don't think that I'm in denial and
think it's actually the perfect thing so
one we don't deal with very with very
big overfitting
of our data either to the fact that
we're all training to the same world
testing on the same test sets or that
our training set is not representative
in because we can't cross validate we're
not really sure
maybe with regularization or other
techniques you can have some idea but we
don't really deal when I estimate what
the error that how over fit my model is
you don't deal with something like
extremely imbalance classes classes that
appear very very very rarely why because
unless you do a lot of iterations you
might not sample those very very rare
classes right so then you end up in the
same problem that you had why can't you
cross can't cross validate okay I'm
boots trap well if I need to do 10
million bootstraps I'm in the same
problem that I was before and the other
thing is there's an upward bias to our
estimates where all we're saying where
there's more error than there is it's
for a statistical reason which I'm not
going to prove to you
subsampling is-is-is upward bias and
there are estimates anyway that's that's
a whole other discussion but if you want
to know why we can talk about it after
and and oops the other thing is we made
a little mistake what do we do we added
a random noise right but many models
count them the fact that there are
between feature correlations so for
example if you were a decision tree you
might say well if X is greater than 10
and Y is less than 3 well then it's
really about not a human traffic right
so in that case in that case we're
breaking or we're lowering the the
correlation so you would need to do we
need to also deal with the covariance
right so that's this model didn't help
you there right
but overestimating your error is
generally not such a bad thing right I'd
rather say that are more wrong and
actually be right more than I said then
the opposite right which is sorry you
might that's absolutely true it's
absolutely true right
so yes you have to do with governance so
my solution isn't perfect and there's
more stuff that we can do and if you're
really interested to hear how you can
make it even better and you don't mind
listening to some math come up
afterwards and I'll show you some hidden
slides okay so thanks a lot any
questions yeah yes so the question was
what helped me come up with those ideas
honestly it was it was mostly
observation that we that we just keep in
these single numbers and I didn't
understand how you could say something
is better from a single number I mean I
don't know what's the expectation on a
single number you know it's it's like a
gamblers dilemma kind of problem so it
seemed like there had to be some way to
estimate well get one of the things that
made who gave me the idea there's a
paper by Efron who's the guy who
invented the bootstrap from Stanford it
was like 90 something and still writing
papers so he wrote this in he wrote this
kind of article about this bootstrap
which he calls the 6-3 to
spooch don't know if you ever heard of
this but the idea is basically that when
you when you resample you have a chances
of resampling that go anyway that when
you take a the limit of your scent
interview of your test set to infinity
it goes to 1 over E which is 0.3 to 8 so
0.632 so he waits is he waits the
bootstrapping in such a ways to deal
with the upward bias and when I thought
about him doing this bootstrap I thought
oh well actually you could do that just
for estimating there on the test set so
that's one inspiration remember the
other authors but if you look at the
latest Efron or one of the latest Efron
papers got it so the question was why
use subsampling versus resampling right
and that was the first question and the
second question is well what about using
things like smote or any of these kind
of under oversampling things so I'll
answer the second question first
the second question is about training
you would use smote for example on your
training set if you wanted to balance if
you wanted to more if you wanted to get
a more balanced estimate of your if you
wanted your model to deal with
imbalances in occupation that you use
like averages averages from different
samples then you somehow yeah buts mode
is about is about class bounce I mean
what you're basically saying is instead
of doing resampling or subsampling at
all you use you smote to augment your
test set and then in the the one of my I
mean you could you could essentially do
this where you would then you end up in
a situation where you need to now add
randomized parameters to smoke right
meaning the idea is that I want a
histogram in the end I don't want a
single number so if I just augment my
tests at once I end up with another
single number I ate another point
estimate so I need a way
to estimate the variance on this point
estimate give me the same result if I
use the same random kernel right so so
then it's still a point estimate so
that's the reason I wouldn't do it also
smoke is generally a thing that you were
doing training rather than test but but
but maybe yeah maybe it's an idea
instead of resampling you could do
instead of robthebruce employ your
subsampling using other island like rose
or smoked or one of those so why did i
subsample instead of resample it's a
very good question so i subsample
instead of resampling because i was
trying to simulate what test taking a
test set actually is test set is a
subsample of reality right and so what I
want to do is say well it's a test that
let's say we're a truly random sub
sample of reality what I want to do is
estimate what's going to happen if i sub
sample the sub sample you know there's
advantages resampling would be would be
better if i wanted to estimate it's a
whole other statistical discussion but
but recently if I want to estimate the
variance and uh if I want to estimate
the variance on the point estimate in
this case sub settling makes more sense
than resembling if I wanted to estimate
variance directly rather rather than
variance at the point estimate then
resampling would make more sense but
maybe we talked about it afterwards
because it's kind of like everything in
deep learning it's sometimes more art
than science right so you'd have to
choose you'd have to choose your your
higher-order things that you want to
very smartly write and the better you
choose them the more estimate the better
your estimate of your error is going to
be there's no perfect you know there's
no there's no perfect solution right in
any case that's going to take some of
your expertise especially in deep
learning where for example it's very
domain-specific right like if I'm not
talking about if I'm talking about cats
and dogs right I might care about
backgrounds or average image brightness
or other things that could preserve or
you know I don't know color of the fur
or all sorts of things like that or size
of the animal perspective in the image
all sorts of things like this but if I
were talking about smile faces you know
or sad faces
then maybe the face orientation is much
more important than how bright the
images for example within certain normal
bounce right so again it requires domain
knowledge and no I can tell you right
now no estimate of your error is
actually going to be perfect right I
mean and for deep learning again or
large neural networks that take a long
time to Train you're never gonna get you
know the best way is bootstrap your
training but if you can't do that then
I'm just giving the next best but you
make strong point you're saying is it
snow so I'm still doing the subsampling
and adding noise each time right because
I'm what I'm doing is for example if I
had in my example of maybe I can yeah so
in this example right so what I did was
I calculated the the face angles and I
looked at the variance in that right and
I have a distribution now which has ads
zero to my face angle of a particular
case on average but occasionally with
according to the merits pluck a number
that's either positive or negative to my
to each set so what I'm doing is in each
sub sample I'm adding this dis nose
essentially right so basically instead
of calling this function okay just add
select a random number I would select a
random number and then have an
additional line of code that says you
know wore my image by turning it from
that with that number yeah
so yes it's more work with neural
networks it's yeah but but the code is
still very simple right because you
would just you know you you think of a
few higher-order parameters that you
know your network is is it not robust to
and those are the ones you want to mess
around with to find out how
yeah so but then again we're going back
to the training problem right so I what
you're saying is okay so take my
training take my training look at what
the weights are after the training is
completed and then try to find out let's
say the nodes like the higher the the
the deeper nodes are responding to
higher-order features and so maybe those
will give me a hint on which features I
could pretend that's that's that's yeah
why not but then yeah I mean it won't it
well you'll be in a problem though if
again if you're very over fate or your
or your data set is large enough for all
sorts of other issues that I didn't talk
about in this talk but in general yeah
that's a good suggestion for maybe
getting a twitch which things you could
be robust to okay so that's it for now
anyone who's more interested in math
Thanks